ya un amalgame qui a été créé sur les
réseaux sociaux
je pense volontairement aujourd'hui 1
depuis le mois de mai donc moi si si je
suis venu ici ce soir sur ce plateau je
vais vous le dire très clairement c'est
uniquement par rapport à mes enfants par
rapport à ma famille parce que demain
c'est la rentrée des classes et que j'ai
pas envie que ma famille que mes enfants
rentrent dans la cour de récréation avec
la boule au ventre comme elles l'ont
depuis trois mois et demi
parce qu'il s'est dit des choses sur ce
plateau lundi
qui sont pour moi
impardonnable c'est quoi ces choses
alors dites-nous les quelque chose vous
avez donné la parole à un homme qui
marcel d'une manière inouïe et violence
on a trois mois et demi à beaucaire vous
avez donné la parole à l'avocat et puis
et puis et puis personne et la barre des
9 de la personne autiste aussi qu'il
aurait pu dire il a fait cas se garer
sur le côté et prendre le temps de le
dire c'est pas de votre faute s'il l'a
pas dit je pense ce que vous lui avez
donné cette parole mais vous avez donné
la parole à cette personne alors que ça
fait trois mois et demi que cette
personne a commencé à me harceler avec
toute cause rien à voir avec les
placements de produits ça a commencé
depuis le 17 mai avec des tweets qui
n'avait strictement rien à voir avec les
placements produits et qui petit à petit
a créé l' amalgame justement je pense
volontairement sur les placements de
produits
et ça pour moi c'est pas pardonnable
d'avoir c'est inacceptable d'avoir
occulté ce qui s'est passé dans ma vie
depuis trois mois et demi mais on est
comme une famille si vous l'avez dit à
plusieurs reprises et j'ai entendu
toutes les discours que vous avez tenus
sur l'oppression fait du rejet ou non
mais dans les faits
ils avaient le droit de vous exprimer
mais l'avocat ne vous a pas à attaquer
ils ont dit leur vérité je vais dire va
mieux oui mais j'ai le droit de dire la
mienne les étapes et c'est justement au
décès souplesse
illégal mais j'ai gagné ici c'est moi
qui donne la parole donc je vais vous
dire ce que vous allez dire ou pas dire
même si vous prenez un droit de réponse
j'ai droit de démarrer mais c'est moi le
chef du plateau donc quand je suis fière
aujourd'hui je suis pas cramé mais oui
mais quand je dis quand je dis stop stop
donc je vais vous expliquer quelque
chose magali vers la magazine nous ce
que veulent les gens c'est ce que
veulent savoir les français si si il ya
des arnaques ou pas je vais vous dire la
guéguerre booba magali berda bien sûr
c'est pas énorme mais non mais ça fait
de la peine à tout le monde ça fait
d'affamer la même série que ça gêne tout
le monde ça fait de la salle est bondée
surprise pour voici en disant mais vous
écoutez une question vous pouvez vous
aviez votre enfant qui vous demandez est
vrai c est ce que c'est ce trait aux
bornes au graal est juste qu'on lui
envoie par milliers je continue de
recevoir aujourd'hui soit c'est ça n'est
pas le sujet une essence reviendrait
pour sa vaste demeure de l'abbé j'ai à
vous dire d'aidé qui savent est au
rendez vous dans sa veste pour dire les
téléspectateurs non non je vous dis
répondu julien g vous dire s'ils vont
bien elles elles occultent le sujet dit
que la vérité je lui ai dit que vous
êtes encore c'est que vous avez des
contrôles soient pas du tout et vous de
culte et le sujet en tout cas si on
voulait savoir ce soir parce que je vais
vous expliquer ça râle a dit j'ai ouvert
j'ai été la seule agence à ouvrir les
portes en avril pour les modèles
actuellement en chantier non mais je
vous dis et je le sens je réponds à tous
donc là transparent gagné région décide
seul à le faire seul mandat ce soit et
moi aujourd'hui dans quatre sections
semences et je vis ce mois aux autorités
policières j'ai la police que chez moi
tous les jours j'ai dû déménager en 24
heures d'accord les ministres enfants ma
fille ça sent déjà triste tous nos
regards des basques du tout et ça sur
votre platine ne réponds pas je vote mc
mazel il magali peu voyant ce qui se dit
sur les réseaux je vous dire ce qui se
dit sur les réseaux qui regardent ils se
remettent mais je m'en vais nommer parce
que je vous donne un conseil faut que je
donne un conseil c'est pas bien je vous
dire magali faut arrêter c'est les gens
disent elles occultent les réponses en
parlant de ça ne doit venir aider mais
ils foncent allez-vous un complément
d'enquêté le 8 et nancy ont censuré les
réponses et on vous a témoigné les
portes de mon agence vous avait occulté
volontairement ou pas je n'en sais rien
lundi et pour moi c'est pas par donna
pourquoi parce que vous êtes tous au
courant tous au courant de ce qui
m'arrive depuis trois mois et demi vous
êtes tous au courant je vous ai tous
signalés ce qui m'arrivait mêmes avouent
syrie vous êtes au courant de ma fille a
été agressée méfier mais tous dans la
rue a commencé comme ça je pense que
c'est une guerre sur les réseaux sociaux
mire des dizaines de milliers de
messages de mort et de décapitations je
m'en excuse mais pélisson le sait on le
dit on la dit cent fois ici mais magali
ce sont des fans de de booba il a une
très grosse commune où est inacceptable
sinon c'est pas acceptable personnel
mais même lui n'accepte pas un sale et
menace de mort j'en ai parlé avec mes
arrières 10 qui l'accepté pas j'ai une
chose à vous lire quand j'ai supplié
booba sur les réseaux sociaux en
exposant certes deux ou trois menaces de
mort que je recevais en disant ma
famille est en danger de mort booba
répondu noir sur blanc sur twitter il
vous aurait fallu d'y aller y aller pour
le savoir au plus tu agonise et au plus
ça m'excite est-ce qu'on peut
m'expliquer ce que c'est le rapport
entre eux mon agonie et le placement de
produit puis c'est quoi ça ça sent le
coach un rapport on est ici personne
personne ça je suis le mossad les
services secrets israéliens en sachant
très bien les répercussions qu'il va y
avoir de suez puisque on sait ce que ça
engendre derrière n'est ce pas recevoir
des milliers de menaces de messages
antisémites et cetera et cetera c'est
quoi le rapport avec mon physique c'est
quoi le rapport avec ma fille de 14 ans
qui gère et sa silhouette c'est en
rapport avec est sympa normal de
demander à tous mes influences heures de
quitter son intelligence sinon ils vont
subir le même harcèlement que je subis
moi même non mais ça c'est normal c'est
pas nous
cette façon nos dictionnaires moi j'ai
vécu cet été quand il vous a aussi
appelé sur les réseaux sociaux oui et
vous le savez vous de michel je
l'appelais j'ai eu une discussion avec
lui et voilà tu es très bien entré dans
le rang mais j'aurais bien aimé que vous
m'appeliez aussi c'est vrai qu'on
travaille ensemble on vous a plu j'ai
toujours dit les filles j'ai déjeuné
avec vous avant la pente en armes et
betty enjoint cyril en a mangé ensemble
dans cet aîné real heureusement il s'est
passé beaucoup de choses mais c'est
vague ali ici on n'est pas la peau nous
on est tous triste de ce qui vous arrive
vous ni on est tous financière et crise
là aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il
faut que vous expliquez que votre
société est propre c'est tout voilà
c'est le nerf de la guerre je vous le
dis et je vous donne c'est un conseil
que je vous donne c'est pas nous on
essaie là je vous parle en commun un
grand frère si je vous dis qu'il me
parlait de dire si j'étais son devoir
les pauses vous le savez vous êtes
vraiment les conséquences et pouvoir les
moyens avant même chez sean event ce que
je m'occupe
un contrôle un berger directeur j'ai
appelé du rectorat de shaughnessy
donville pas d'idée nous avait reconnu
du bout de la caisse juridique tout
était besoin de me justifier là-dessus
vous avez répondu allant même série les
gens continuent le des questions heureux
parce que il ya une personne aujourd'hui
sur les réseaux sociaux qui a commencé à
marteler sur des tonnes de choses qui
n'ont rien à voir avec les placements
effectivement il ya eu des failles sur
les placements de produits ce n'est pas
en secret ça fait deux ans et cette fine
ça fait 10 ans j'appelle à réguler les
placements produits et que je dis je
vous invite à regarder les 6 et 5 % le
fn 21 non j'ai été transparents ou jésus
où les fautes bêtes des règles en place
il faut mettre des règles claires en
place pour toutes les agences et tous
les influenceurs gelé moi même dit en
2021 je les reconnais c'est sûr mais
réseau je n'ai pas à être menacés de
mort aujourd'hui personne à être menacés
de mort au moule ni personne à être
menacés de mort n'a même mais voilà
c'est ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
pas bien sur l'eau comme il y avait
actionné évidemment pourquoi je lui dis
pourquoi je lui dis l'expliquer parce
que c'est la cause et ce quand on aura
s'est classé comme c'est comme si on a
une plaie si on ne met pas un gars ou de
suite ça va t'en va pas parler on va pas
dire on a mal on a mal et rien faire il
faut expliquer aux gens qui nous
regardent et aux gens qui vous
critiquent sur les réseaux et leur dire
que votre société pour vous et pour vous
elle est clean même lundi cyril encore
une fois vous êtes actionnaire mais
c'est vous la viande est très heureux je
la connais pas ni rejet c'est pas une
petite anse ruse et moi je suis moi je
connais pas les procédés vous croyez
vraiment je suis dans les comptes de koh
lanta ou de démarrer l'année jean zay
pas une petite je savais qu'à des
contrôles internes et vous les cadets
contrôle de gestion et avec la bonne
chose mais magali jeu actionnaires de
l'amitié je vais pas contrôler excusé
pour ses tv diffuse et moi me vous le
savez cyril si je suis désolé on essaie
on essaie de savoir vous parlez de
choses qui ne vous plaisent pas et c'est
ce qui me plaît pas c'est quoi qui ne
sais pas ce que je dis des mots mais
c'est quoi qui chroniqueuse ici depuis
quatre ans peut être que vous n'allez
pas me garder j'ai pas de problème avec
sa magnifique appareil a aucun problème
quelqu'un je suis je ne suis pas là ben
voyons on voit ce qu'ils faisaient et la
sécurité de mes enfants c'est
essentiellement une émission télévision
et justement va gagner la sécurité de
votre mouvement et votre dignité elle
passe par les explications et quand vous
avez tout expliquer tout se passera bien
c'est tout passé ce qu'on vous dit plus
de salaires donc ici vous êtes et quand
vous allez dire les choux une victime de
viol doit expliquer pourquoi elle est un
peu trop décolleté ou et ses soutiens
n'avoir
on n'est pas qu'elle tombe dans le mêmes
démons victime est une victime
aujourd'hui darcel mais on est prêts
faibles ont maintenant fait quoi
expliquer pourquoi les loyers tout en
même temps
additionnel de déclarations c'est à dire
que ces mamies daniélou dans la tête je
lis déjà d'en bas oui déjà mais dans ce
cas là on a envie moi j'ai envie de toi
te poser des questions toutes simples et
oui mais les gens craignent que je suis
en état de répondre à vos questions je
les fais au mois d'avril je le fais
depuis deux ans quand on recevait des
messages toutes les minutes ch depuis
trois mois ça veut ennemis constater par
huissier du ici toutes les minutes et
oui tout rory plus les uns que les
autres tous les jours est ce que vous
croyez nous allons envie d'aller sur un
plateau télé d'hier est ce qu'il ya une
fraude ou panon les déchets c'est sûr et
cela cause contrôle de la répression des
fraudes nous contrôler la répression des
fraudes fait son travail booba n'est pas
la répression des fraudes yann et
l'ancien d'alert qui existe sur internet
depuis des années desquels on s'inspire
desquels on regarde même parce qu'on
apprend même avec eux mais parce qu ils
ne m'ont jamais agressé il a toujours
été fait dans le respect ça on a besoin
de balancer mon adresse à la nation le
c'est magali rowland est d'accord il va
demander mon avis
on n'était pas là pour ça on est là pour
expliquer aux gens le problème à celle
exercée sur les spectateurs seulement
c'est un support mais mais il ya plein
de gens sur les réseaux des
consommateurs des consommateurs de
produits qui sous l'égide de votre
société sont vendus qui se plaignent
qu'ils disent que ça n'arrive pas donc
moi ma question aller simple pour
répondre à ces consommateurs qui se
plaignent est ce que vous avez eu
connaissance de ça si vous avez eu
connaissance et ce qui a eu des normes
qui ont été mises en place est ce que
vous pouvez dire au consommateur que
grâce à des protocoles qui ont été
effectués ça n'arrivera plus c'est ça
qui intéresse les gens qui je suis
répond puisque c'est ça qui vous
intéresse et le drop shipping y en a eu
vers 2019 à peu près sa sortie à ce
moment là où il ya eu des vagues de drop
shipping et influenceurs donc je pense
que tu dois le savoir
malheureusement oui effectivement il ya
eu plein de choses nous ça fait
maintenant quasiment deux ans qu'on a
décidé donc très rapidement parce qu'on
est en 2022 de limiter les mares de drop
shipping c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
chez shell advance depuis quasiment deux
ans on en fait quasiment plus je vais
pas dire on n'en fait plus parce que ça
serait mentir on en fait quasiment plus
mais ce qu'on a gardé ce que
dropshipping c'est légal ce sont des
drogues schipper qu'on connaît avec qui
on travaille sur qu'il n'y a pas de
soucis qu'ils le font très bien parce
que c'est quand même il ya des gens qui
sont très bien c'est comme de partout il
ya des gens bien et des gens papier
voilà donc on a limité effectivement
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on a une
âme baisses de chiffre d'affaires qui
est conséquente aussi depuis un an et
demi deux ans parce qu'on a refusé
énormément de sites on refuse de plus en
plus de sites on a créé un service
juridique on a mis plein de choses en
place et ça ça date d'il ya deux ans
maintenant pour que ce soit propre si
vous voulez que le milieu de l'influent
soit propre et je les ai déjà dit donc
c'est pour ça que c'est pas que je ne
veux pas m'en justifiée parce que je
trouve que je n'ai pas mon justifier je
l' ai déjà fait mais je vais le redire
si ça vous intéresse il faut qu'il y ait
des règles qui soient mis en place j'ai
contacté plusieurs
personnes dont des autorités compétentes
l'année dernière pour la demande et des
rendez-vous pour parler avec eux pour
discuter pour leur proposer des choses
parce que je suis sur le terrain depuis
2016 et que j'estime bas que voilà c'est
intéressant et
j'attends j'attends les rendez vous la
dgccrf effectivement suite à tout ça il
ya deux trois ans à activer énormément
de contrôle ils sont très présents ils
ne lâchent rien et je peux vous le dire
parce que je les reçois systématiquement
ils mettent des amendes ils mettent des
sanctions quand il y avait des sanctions
et si un jour chez naïve us doit avoir
une sanction elle aura une sanction il
n'y a pas de débat en fait on ne doit
pas arnaquer les gens si c'est ça votre
question on cfa matin moi j'ai créé
cette société je me suis faite toute
seule tu me connais gym sa prison sans
mandat écrit monte avec la population
mondiale x je suis sait d'où je viens
j'ai travaillé dur et je ne peux pas
aujourd'hui accepter que une personne
crée un amalgame et qu'ils mettent tout
le monde dans le même panier parce qu'il
ya des gens qui ont envie d'évoluer ya
des gens qui sont propres à des gens qui
font des concessions il ya des gens qui
ont décidé de gagner peut-être moins
d'argent mais de faire les choses
proprement c'est possible oui mais il y
en a certains qui ne veut pas et ça je
n'en suis pas responsable d'accord nous
on propose des postes à des influenceurs
ils sont libres de les accepter de les
refuser nous on fait un premier travail
juridique au préalable et basta voilà
c'est tout et s'il faut faire encore
s'il faut faire durcir je le ferai on le
fera il n'y a pas de débat voilà c'est
tout moi je sais quoi c'est quoi si tu
sembles pas il ya dix n'ont pas de
formation c'est pfc oui oui en fait le
cps et le compte personnel de formation
ces navires que aujourd'hui chaque
salarié a de l'argent donc il dispose
pour se former avant ils devaient se
former dans certains secteurs maintenant
c'est plus large donc il ya énormément
de gens qui vont contacter les gens lui
disant tiens vous avez de l'argent sur
votre compte personnel de formation
j'aimerais vous former à 10 ans à ckoi
pardon il ya une arnaque à ça c'est quoi
en cela il ya une arnaque parfois c'est
à dire que certains estiment que l'on
vous contacter on vous dit tiens je
voudrais te former à je ne sais pas quoi
faire du drop shipping ou je sais pas
quoi et que du coup ça n'entre pas dans
les attributions du cpf ou alors on vous
dit cyril vous avez 2000 euros de cpf
cyril on va faire un accord tu vas me
donner 1000 euros en cash tu vas me
donner 1000 euros en cash et moi pour
1000 euros je vais te faire une
formation bidon voit un accord c'est des
systèmes de formation a dit non et non
et si le ministère l'économie
ce qu on le fait ça à nous on ne fait
plus et on a arrêté de parler de cp
depuis le mois de février celle que nous
nous inspirant ça pour ça on l'a on a
tout le temps comme on le sait plus dans
les bric on demande que ce soit plus un
argument parce que malheureusement il ya
des gens malhonnêtes qui passent des
accords avec des gens et tout et nous on
veut pas rentrer là dedans donc quand on
a su parce que les gens vont purger la
musique l'hérault mal sentie glissa
échec sur internet ça va très vite
surclassé plus à abane on n'en fait plus
mais c'est pas parce qu'une entreprise
est agréé par le cepex qu'elle est
qu'elle est malhonnête en fait cela dit
abu lisez tout le monde il ya eu des
gens alors nous ça nous concerne pas
dans le sens où les gens qu'on allait
enfin les centres de formation qu'on à
promotionner pour l'instant c'est pas
une fois partie de ceux qui ont eu les à
ma connaissance ce qu'ils ont été
voilà mais il y en a certains qui en ont
fait oui voilà mais ça ça me concerne
pas mais quand bien même c'est un
argument qui
encourage ces gens là à
arnaquer les gens eh ben on a décidé de
ne plus en parler du tout même s'il ya
des gens très bien on préfère bien sûr
là on arrive voilà exactement alors
aujourd'hui magali donc là comme tu nous
l'as dit tu as eu de nombreux contrôles
je tiens à dire aussi que shauna evans
maintenant fait partie du groupe banijay
comme tu me l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est
râpé ou est ce la rappeler je vais te
dire oui je suis actionnaire du groupe
benji mais comme tu le sais je me mets
pas mon nez dans les comptes et dans
tout ce qui est fait il ya plein de
choses qui sont faites dans le groupe
vous actionnaires que je peux pas
blairer je te le dis tu vois les
marseillais je regarde pas une fois je
trouve que c'est voilà j'ai alors qu'on
est voilà il ya d'autres trucs et je ne
vends que moi là donc je vais te dire et
je n'ai jamais dit oui les marseillais
c'est pour il faut l'arrêter donc voilà
donc je te dis je connais pas tout ce
qui se passe dans toutes les sociétés du
groupe il se trouve que quand même il ya
un directeur général a banni dié qui
gère aussi la société et quand même
voilà qui m'a assuré voilà qu'il y avait
aucune base des relations et aux échos
vis-à-vis des contrôles très réguliers
de différents organismes tu savais pas
ce que c'était que ces organismes qui
contrôle et donc cesser ces sociétés
mais apparemment on est c'est la société
la plus contrôlée sur l'influencé
s'inscrire oui parce que il ya
malheureusement cet amalgame sur les
réseaux sociaux liés à ma personne qui
tue que que booba a développé la
d'accord et donc ça là et quand tu dis
il a fait oui là c'est une api la fin
juin voilà moi savoir qui a des enquêtes
qu'on sait qu'ils sont ouvertes sur ce
que je subis d'accord si je parle pas
dans le vent je suis pas pour me
victimise et ont fait j'en ai rien à
faire de me victimise est aujourd'hui à
personne qui va m'aider ou qui va les
cette image ici la police en donc voilà
non mais très grand moment les seuls qui
vont pouvoir mais jojo savard police
donc je j'ai confiance en la justice pas
d'accord ce qui ce qui monte laissé les
téléspectateurs aussi quand on leur
explique bien des choses et on y qui
voit qu'ils comprennent que oui mais là
l'affairé 5 1 pour qu'elles aient besoin
d'expliquer sans voir par leurs
pressions ces haut parleurs si on
s'intéresse à ce business encore une
fois j'ai été toujours d'ailleurs on en
a déjà parlé ici des placements de
produits on a déjà parlé de ça je suis
désolé on n'a pas personnes attendues
booba pour en parler on en a déjà parlé
ici et à chaque fois j'ai été là pour en
parler avec transparence voilà et je
leur ferai tout le temps et s'il faut
durcir on durcira mais je ne peux pas
tolérer un harcèlement en meute d'accord
je sens par leur espace voilà c'est pas
possible oui mais la sphère a commencé
comme ça c'est que juste veux juste que
chronologiquement on remette les choses
à leur place et c'est pour ça que je
suis venu parce que je veux que les gens
qui vous regardent l'entendre parce
qu'elle en dise non pas attendre ils
n'ont pas entendu bien commencé pour moi
harcèlement l' enquête a été ouverte
pour moi harcèlement les menaces ou quoi
tout mis dans la tête de booba sont
venus ce que mme lagarde a dit c'est que
le placement de produit sur un prétexte
pour cyber harcelé c'est ce que vous
dites pour ben oui qu'est ce qui s'est
passé au départ
je ne sais pas je ne connais pas booba
en fait je ne le sais pas je ne connais
pas cette personne je n'ai jamais
travaillé que lui je ne lui ai jamais
parlé parce que booba ce qui dit je te
le dis ma gni comme ça en moins moi je
pense qu il ya exactement un mois je lui
parlerai également il dit qu'en fait lui
sa guerre c'est contre vous parce que il
n'y voit l'allèle tous ces gens là sont
des concerts de la société et qu'ils
arnaque les gens qui arnaquent son
public qu'ils arnaque mon public qui
sernhac ttt clients et que voilà c'est
ce qu'il dit et c'est bon exemple quand
on me dit que c'est son combat voilà est
ce que toi aujourd'hui
tu as le sentiment que il a des preuves
sur sa comme quoi c'est pas que tu vois
pas ce qu'il y'a pas que toi y'a pas que
magali bertin comme société
d'influenceurs en a plein d'autres et
apparemment de ce qu'on dit en plus ce
serait là la plus propre shauna evans
mois la précieuse moi j'en suis très
loin c'est honnêtement c'est que m mais
qu'est ce tu dis ces lanceurs
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui fait qui dit
qu' il ya des gens qui se font arnaquer
il ya des gens qui aient à yaya diané ya
des gens qui nous regardent qui achètent
des produits quatre fois plus cher alors
que voilà ça coûte 10 balles et il est
et ça n'aurait peut-être handball hockey
est ce que c'est ça ça c'est ce que
c'est la vérité ou pas mais je viens de
l'expliquer évidemment qui avec des
démons c'était un nouveau métier pas
très longtemps c'est allé très vite
aujourd'hui ça n'est plus un nouveau
métier on n'a plus droit aux erreurs
qu'on avait droit au début forcément on
était pas voilà ça sans cadre au fur et
à mesure et encore une fois il faut
mettre des règles en place si je dis ça
c'est que bien évidemment qu'il ya eu il
ya eu des études mais c'est pas
maintenant en fait elle a lui dit envie
de vous dire c'est un peu tard parce que
des lanceurs dallaire qui en a avant il
y en a eu depuis des années ils sont sur
les réseaux sociaux et encore une fois
ils le font proprement parce qu'à partir
du moment où on se rend compte qu'il ya
une grande problème les choses en place
après on va parler partiellement mais au
niveau parce que voilà je vais lancer un
appel d'ailleurs à tous les gens voient
là parce que c'est vrai que c'est ccci
domicile il ya des gens qui me disent
que la femme de david douillet aussi a
fait une vidéo comme quoi il s'était
fait arnaquer les nombreux fans david
douillet est là elle a pris en placement
chez nous l'influencent eux n'a pas
placé sèche était même pas là je vous
explique ce qui s'est passé je sortais
excusez moi je suis membre de ma
belle-soeur donc j'ai pas suivi son truc
quand tu arrivé dans l'entreprise elle a
fait des vidéos partout sur les réseaux
sociaux pour dire j'ai pas eu mon
placement etc elle a été remboursée elle
voulait absolument parler j'étais pas en
jeu je suis désolé j'étais si vous savez
ce qui mettrait l'année dernière voilà
et donc écoutez le l'assistant du
directeur enfin le responsable
commercial l'a appelé le poste n'a pas
été fait ou je crois qu'il a été pour
lui en a offert je sais plus et c'est en
fait on peut pas à chaque à chaque fois
qu'on n'est pas contents d'un truc à les
appeler voilà il ya eu sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce que vous êtes en train
savez on a à peu près peut-être 3500
clients par an je vous laisse un calcul
depuis 2016 si j'en ai une ou deux qui
se plaignent sur les réseaux sociaux qui
sont pas content j'ai envie de dire je
suis désolé on n'est pas parfait aucune
entreprise française n'est parfaite et
que des fois je ne sais même pas si elle
a tort à la raison que c'est peut-être
nous qui avons tort je suis pas là pour
parler de ça en fait mais mais sait on
est une entreprise comme une autre il ya
des choses des fois qu'ils se font bien
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'aujourd'hui
nous nos influences heures sont en
conformité nous on leur demande de
mettre les hashtags cerise et de
prévenir le consommateur depuis 2017 et
ça c'est pas moi qui le dis je c'est
tout le monde nous on demande à nos
influences heures de prévenir le
consommateur qui sont payés pour cette
promotion depuis 2010 est d'accord on a
été un des seuls sur le marché un des
seuls parce qu'elle a certains qui le
font je suis pas là pour dire c'est moi
la meilleure pas du tout il y en a qui
le font il y en a qui le font pas voilà
donc mais en tout cas nous on demande
donc c'est tout il ya des choses qui
sont bien pas bien comme partout mais
c'est pas une raison vous on va
reprocher quelque chose que vous avez
fait aussi de la pub pour une injection
à dubaï n'ont pas de nom pas du tout moi
j'essaie de promotion alors ça a été dit
dans les gentils j'ai fait la promotion
magali berne a fait la promotion pour la
chirurgie esthétique c'est entièrement
faux je n'ai jamais fait de promotion
pour la chirurgie esthétique tout
simplement parce que c'est illégal après
s'il ya des influenceurs tire mon fait
malheureusement je ne suis pas
responsable de leurs gestes dans sur
leurs réseaux sociaux ça leur appartient
les réseaux sociaux hommes sont faits
pour montrer votre dis donc
malheureusement je peux pas tout
contrôler et est bien évidemment que je
leur dise ils le font c'est interdit
mais en tout cas pas mon agence par ma
responsabilité ou par moi même mois
toutes les opérations de chirurgie
esthétique que j'ai fait je les ai
payées et je n'ai pas fait de promotions
n'a jamais demandé faire de la pub voilà
donc magali